I love you you got was so heavy that my
I was like hold on my biceps are shaking
she was shaking shaking this is true
Texas girl though because this is a vat
of queso I love it Jenna made it Jenna
made it it's it's her own personal
recipe I don't want to reveal where you
can find it but if you get Vita and you
turn it over on the back yall know Vita
R right that's Texas this is a single
serving in Texas it is yes it is yep you
could do it for a family of four kids
don't eat very much well what's great is
you just reheat it keep it the I'm all
about that yeah that's right me too
welcome welcome to 30 R you it's going
to be so
fun it we've been waiting for you you
fit here like a puzzle piece we're going
to be looking for you in the elevators
and everywhere around I know and thank
you for being a part of the opening it
fun it was really fun God I love you
guys so much so wait do you do you love
your Dorman do you know your Dorman
really well yeah well we have I you know
C CJ is a legend and in fact I have more
pictures with CJ in front of the
Rockefeller Christmas tree than my
husband yeah yeah wait what oh yeah
because CJ's here every day and I bring
my kids and CJ and I are standing there
and he's the best CJ is that guy CJ's
that
guy when we bring our kids here because
that's like a a field trip that happens
once a month or whatever the first
person they ask about yes is CJ like is
CJ here
yeah that's so beautiful to represent
that kind of consistency for kids too
like you know yeah and tell me when your
kids come so I'll bring mine okay we I
keep promising playdates like I promise
it'll happen give me a minute so I heard
that you just recently visited your high
school is this right you went back to
your high school with your siblings yeah
my brother my sister and I went back to
Fort Hunt High School in Alexandria
Virginia and you know when you roll up
it was for all the grade so we rolled up
and that was my little daughter hope who
was there who came too and it was I got
to tell you Kelly it was one of the
funnest things I've done in a while and
I was one of those kids who never got
asked out on any dates ever I went
through high school like it was like I
was like the weird kid you know I had
the stop sign
glasses weird anyway except for one kid
asked me to go to a dance yeah and his
name was Pete Samuelson oh you remember
the full name I love it I love it girl I
rolled up and you know who walked up to
me no way cute as a button with his wife
wearing flipflops and I looked at I was
like there you're that's the guy and it
was just the it was just super sweet
that's super cool like the nostalgic
memories too and like what a sweet thing
for you to say to him like look you like
made that happen for me I so special and
you asked me yeah that's so cool oh my
gosh um what about your high school
experience do you have any fun ones
yours must have been that's hard no I
was high school was a little was normal
I went to Austin High School in Austin
okay okay and it was so much fun it was
like Friday Night Lights you know and
but I will say my senior year you know
how you get the superlatives my
boyfriend was most likely to be on the
cover of GQ congratulations my twin
sister who we don't really look alike
was most likely to be on the cover of
Vogue yeah and I was most likely to trip
across the stage at graduation and then
when I you know Dr drank a little early
when I shouldn't have people were like
it was cuz she was drunk oh she was
drunk I was like no y'all I'm was a CL
oh my gosh just not graceful me neither
not graceful
specific I was like Mom and Dad aren't
you so proud what was your superlative
in high school talented I think I got
most talented or something like that
yeah I got I got which it was the only
thing really that I was a complete
Wallflower like nobody knew who I was
until I started singing and then they
like you're the girl that sings and I
was like yeah I mean I've been here for
a minute but sure which is also crazy oh
my God I was very shy I was very no but
I think this is very true and like for
anybody that has kids it's so important
to get them involved in things and let
let them find something that they feel
special
when I found sely my ched I was very sh
I know think I'm lying but I I was and
and I think all shy kids are kind of
have this little you know you know
person inside that wants to get out and
be an extrovert but you just don't have
the opportunity you don't feel um
comfortable enough or confident yet but
yeah I got I got most talented important
right I did I did get best sense of
humor oh well that works and then we
also had class clown but I didn't get
that I was the guy who in the way back
and was like look at this clown you were
making fun of the CL fun of the clown
yeah you're a level up I get it I get it
we have to do another commercial break
everybody today with Hoda and Jenna airs
weekdays on NBC up next we've got a game
Jenna and Hoda versus
Stephanie it's a 30 Rock Showdown y'all
we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home